All right,
we are on location at the blaze studios
here in Dallas,
Texas and I'm sitting across from Mr
Blades.
Glenn Beck or I sir,
how's it going?
My man.
Good to see you.
Thank you for letting us do an on
location.
Shoot.
Not a problem.
I know you're here for about 10 minutes
and then you're,
I think you're going to probably be on
the moon and then a stop at the Mars and
you know a little bit about traveling a
lot.
So I'm in between a thousand things
here.
Uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's pretty cool.
I want to spend a lot of time talking
about this book here,
addicted to outrage,
but let's just do everything.
So right now we're about two and a half
weeks away from this big term election.
I suspect something completely bananas
over the next two and a half weeks.
I mean you can already just see between
between the cabin are stuff that we've
been dealing with the general outrage
and all the things you're writing about
here.
I just said this to a group of friends
the other day.
I think at this point a spaceship could
appear.
Okay and hover over New York City and
it'd be like,
oh,
I mean,
I don't know what would surprise me now
will we be arguing about the gender
pronouns are the aliens?
Yeah,
I know,
I know.
It's,
it's absolutely insane how everything
is.
Everything is upside down.
Do you think,
do you think we're in a unique time?
Because that's one of the questions when
I'm out there with Peterson,
often people will say,
okay,
it's,
you know,
everyone says we've never been more
partisan and were angrier than ever and
all of these things.
But there's something about this seem
unique.
Yeah,
I,
I'm a,
I'm a glutton for history and uh,
it,
we have been in perilous times before.
I don't think we've hit the civil war,
uh,
confrontations yet,
but we are approaching it.
Do you think we really are,
because I can't do because I'm actually
worried about the amount of people.
I used to see this on twitter all the
time.
People saying,
oh,
civil wars come in and you know,
like,
just like murmur about what would be the
most horrific possible outcome of all of
them.
Or remind me to talk about the window
because I think we have a window right
now.
Um,
but we have been,
uh,
we've been worse.
I mean,
if you look at Jefferson and Adams,
Adams Adams was called a Hermaphrodite
by Jefferson Jefferson,
Jefferson,
his campaign,
uh,
called him a hermaphrodite.
Adam said back that if you elect Thomas
Jefferson,
there will be blood in the streets and
the heads of our children and your
daughters will be on Pike's into every
town.
So we've had rhetoric like this
for ironically,
I'd be thrilled to vote for either one
would be like,
I'll take either I don't care heads on
pikes,
that will be fine.
But,
but it all does go to in the last couple
of weeks,
you know,
there was this Hillary Clinton Line on
cnn talking to Christiane Amanpour about
how we can't be civil because these,
these people,
meaning the Conservatives or Republicans
are so against our values.
I mean,
this is dangerous stuff.
So here's the difference,
we have been in these places before,
but we knew our founding documents,
we knew who we served or who are God
was,
and I don't know who our God is now.
I mean,
is it money?
Is it fame?
Is it anger?
I don't know what our God is now.
Um,
we knew.
Wait,
can you wait,
let me pause you there for a sec.
So when you,
when you say that about what the
founders believed,
now they were also saying separation of
church and state the whole time.
So if you were just laying out what they
believed when you say we,
who are.
God was,
um,
so George Washington,
they did believe in the division of
Church and state.
Clearly I do too.
Um,
that just means if you're an atheist,
you're an atheist.
We're friends,
we're cool,
let's get along.
But if you're a god person,
you'd do your God thing.
You do your atheist thing,
right?
Do we have what Adam Smith called moral
sentiment in common?
Yes.
Capitalism has lost the first volume of
Adam Smith.
The second volume is wealth of nations.
The first volume is moral sentiments and
that says,
look,
this is an invisible hand and the market
is powerful and it will create whatever
you want.
Be careful what you ask for.
Make sure you are always tempering the
moral sentiment.
Make sure that you're a good,
decent,
fair minded people.
We've lost that.
We're losing it,
I should say.
Um,
and I'm concerned and I,
I talk about this a bit in the book.
I've seen this coming for almost two
decades and I had been warning against
it and for the very first time I'm at
the place where I'm on the air now
saying,
this is the time,
this is the time that I said would come
and now is the time for you to remember
who you are.
Um,
and our outrage is taking us away from
it.
So as I've looked at this for so long,
I have,
I have studied revolutions,
I've studied giant movements of chaos.
I,
I can tell you about,
you know,
uh,
the,
um,
I think it was the red month,
uh,
in the 19 thirties.
Like,
I can show you what's happened,
but there were three people in for
people in grand movements that have
gotten it right.
There was Abraham Lincoln,
there was Martin Luther King.
There was Gandhi.
Then there's bond bonhoeffer.
Do you know who dietrich bonhoeffer was?
I don't think so.
Bonhoeffer last.
Okay.
Bon hoffer was a,
um,
a,
a pastor,
I think,
Lutheran in Germany.
He was on the air when the fewer
declared.
He was furious.
He was taken.
His broadcast was cutting short because
he was doing a broadcast called the
furor principle.
This is wrong.
Don't go this way.
He on Kristallnacht.
The very next morning he was shopping in
those stores,
those Jewish stores.
I'm a pacifist.
He tried to turn the Germans back and
say,
stop it.
Stop.
You're going the wrong way.
He couldn't do it.
He eventually escaped from Germany.
Was in New York,
not here very long because he felt
guilty.
How can I leave my country when it's in
this much trouble?
He went back.
He realized there's no noise.
Has Stopped.
This guy may be violence is the answer.
He was involved in one of the attempts
to kill Hitler.
He went to a concentration camp.
He died.
He was executed like five days before
Hitler died.
Here's the thing,
if you read his writings,
he's gone to.
He's Jesus.
He's Martin Luther King.
He's,
he's,
he's got it,
and I read them and read them and read
them.
How?
Why did he fail?
Silence in the face of evil is evil
itself not to stand is to stand.
He's got it.
Love one another.
Don't.
Turret stopped playing the organ so you
can hear the train going down.
Twits.
Okay.
He failed because Germans had already
gone over the cliff.
They had because of world war one.
Then the treaty of Versailles.
Then the 19 twenties,
they had already lost their Judeo
Christian principles.
They had lost their center.
Remember,
if it wasn't for England,
Gandhi would have failed.
People think of Gandhi is starving
himself to get the British to comply.
No,
he starved himself to say to his own,
people do not rise up in anger.
They were this close to losing and he
knew it.
He was appealing to the sense of decency
and fairness of the British culture,
so he knew the people because of their
Judeo Christian worldview would see this
oppression and go,
that's wrong.
If we have a window and it's closing,
if we give into our anger,
our outrage,
and we say,
you know what,
I can't take it anymore.
We will lose and that window of the
Judeo Christian values will close and
then we're done.
Yeah.
It's so interesting because one of the
themes that keeps coming up as I'm on
this tour is people
keep asking me about this.
How much worse is it going to get before
there's some sort of reset and all of
these things,
and it's like,
man,
I don't want two months from now or four
years from now to look back at right
before the 2018 elections and go,
boy,
weren't those the good old days because
we've gone on on the train to hell.
So do you think there's actually no way
to stop it at this point?
Do you think that.
No,
I think they behind it.
Here's.
Here's the scenarios that I'm looking at
right now.
If I'm working gaming,
yeah,
none of these.
I know the prediction business always
works out.
So let's see here.
I got it.
So if you're wargaming yeah,
let's look at the next election.
What happens?
Well,
the Democrats probably gonna win the
house.
Okay.
They win the house,
you know,
they're going to at least subpoena his
tax records.
He's not going to give up tax records
and that will be brought to the supreme
court.
Remember that marker number one day
number one,
day number two,
they don't have any place they can go on
impeachment.
They have to impeach him.
Even if they don't have anything they've
already said it.
They have to do,
they have to do it.
It'll be the senate that will throw it,
will throw it to the Senate.
That's where the trial happens.
So impeachment just means or taking you
to court.
So that's day number two.
Day number three,
uh,
trump has already filed with the Supreme
Court saying,
I'm not,
I'm not testifying.
I'm not turning over my tax records.
I'm not doing this.
Okay,
well,
Kevin has already said he's already seen
that that's a distraction.
The president shouldn't have to,
so day number three when trump has
brought it to the Supreme Court,
then the house says,
wait a minute,
Cavanaugh's should recuse himself.
We're looking at a year where,
uh,
the three branches of government,
the administration,
uh,
plus the house and the Senate,
both of them will be fighting with each
other.
They'll be fighting with this branch and
there'll be fighting with the supreme
court.
When cavenaugh doesn't recuse himself,
they will file articles of impeachment
for him.
And they're,
they're leading all of these ideas
already.
I mean,
these ideas are trickling out or.
Yeah.
So now you have the press.
The fourth branch already in chaos has,
has absolutely no credibility at all.
It's deranged.
And that pushes which you would call the
fifth branch or the first branch,
the people into the streets.
How do you solve?
All right?
So before we get to the streets,
can I give you the one option that I
think maybe saves us from all of that,
which is that the Republicans win,
or at least hold in the midterms.
Thus,
finally,
as long shot is,
this is finally the Democrats go,
okay,
we've got to drop identity politics.
We've got to get away from this
socialist,
Democrat,
socialists.
Not that I.
There's no evidence that they would ever
look in the mirror.
If anything,
they've only doubled down every time.
I see that as the only out to where
you're going.
So I think if you have,
if they don't win the house,
if you win the house,
God forbid if they went in the house and
the Senate,
then it's chaos.
But if you win,
if they win the house,
the Democrats,
that scenario is going to play out in
some form or another.
So that just gets worse and worse and
worse.
I was talking to a friend of mine just
last night about this and he said,
you know,
just exactly what you said,
and I followed it up with what you said.
Show me the,
I know there's no evidence I am
spartacus is all of a sudden going to
say,
okay,
I'm not spartacus.
Yeah,
you know,
I'm the carpenter from,
from Nazareth.
Now.
Wasn't that the danger all along?
And this,
this is directly linked to your book.
I mean,
I remember before the election I kept
saying,
yeah,
this is when I still considered myself
on the left and someone that had
basically only voted Democrat my entire
life.
I think the one time I voted Republican
was a Bloomberg's third term in New York
City after he had flipped like 87 times
over or something.
I'm not even sure if he was Republican
at that point.
Um,
but that I kept saying before the
election,
if you keep calling trump Hitler,
then no matter what he does,
and no matter what reality is,
you will never be able to get yourself
out of that little thing place you've
painted yourself.
And that's where we are.
So,
you know,
it's crazy.
I lived this,
I lived this.
I said I'm the guy who got in so much
trouble saying,
I think Barack Obama may be a racist.
Now.
I immediately corrected it in that on
the spot and said,
that's not quite right.
I now understand.
I explain it in the book.
I now understand how to express that.
I wasn't up on anti colonialism.
I certainly wasn't up on postmodernism,
I wouldn't have,
so I'm hearing all these terms that mean
nothing to me and yet they're always
attacking groups to me and to a lot of
people in the country.
That's the definition of racist.
Okay.
But I didn't understand the difference.
The other part,
the other part at.
Okay.
It's now social justice.
Well social justice seems wrong to me.
That's how I defined it then.
That was so divisive what I said that
and I was really at the time struggling
to figure out what is happening,
how is,
who is this guy?
Um,
and I got more and more straightened,
uh,
and
didn't make a lot of friends on the
left.
Okay.
It didn't work.
My base got stronger,
my bass learned things,
but my base also as things went on,
got more and more angry as did I.
Why isn't this working well,
because you cannot call people names and
expect them to come over.
We have,
I just saw a new poll today that shows,
I think it's eight percent of the
American public.
8,000
people interviewed,
eight percent of the American public is
the diehard progressive radical.
Okay.
Um,
the,
uh,
the never give up.
Conservative.
Traditional conservative is about 29
percent.
Okay.
They're both on the edges.
Twenty seven,
29 percent,
somewhere in that area.
Still on the edges.
The vast majority is now being called
the exhausted class and it's the class
of people.
And I'm in this guys.
It doesn't have to be this way.
I don't.
I'm tired of this.
I know.
Not Everybody is a racist.
Not everybody is a homophobe.
It's the stop it.
Stop it.
The cabinet Jordan Peterson got into
trouble and I tweeted,
I tweeted back to him.
I think this might be the first time I
disagree,
but I put I think because,
well,
for people that didn't see it,
basically he said that what would
probably be best.
And he did this in a tweet,
which is never the best way to do it.
Idea.
And He's already.
He's already had his mayor Kulpa on that
and released to a correct correction.
A clarification in a blog form.
Uh,
but basically he said the best outcome
would be the cabinet gets confirmed but
then steps down and what he meant was
that wasn't saying the cabinet did do
anything or didn't do anything,
but if there's any chance for a little
bit of healing where everyone gets a
little egg on their face,
but also it gets a little bit of dignity
to walk away with and the country
doesn't come apart at the seams.
That was what he tried to do in a tweet.
And in his blog post,
he's acknowledged that trying to do that
in a tweet,
probably not the best name,
trying to do that in a tweet.
Um,
where the people who are reading it are
generally all about politics and tearing
each other apart.
Bad idea.
That's why I put,
I think because knowing Jordan the
little that I do,
yeah,
he's a deep philosophical thinker.
So my,
my feeling was,
and it turns out it was right that he's
looking at that and saying,
okay,
in,
in a normal world,
in a good world where we're all really
trying to do the right thing.
And if we really were all trying to do
the right thing,
I agree with him,
it would have been the best thing to
have Jordan say,
or,
or to have Kevin,
I'll say,
thank you,
thank you.
Now let's bring the country back
together.
Nominate somebody else and let's go
through.
But the other side would have gone
through exactly the same thing.
You would have rewarded them in the end
because they got it.
Because we're talking about the machines
of destruction.
So reality doesn't play a role.
At some point,
this 70 percent of America is going to
stand up and say,
shut up,
both of you.
Are you shocked
how many people in that 70 percent are
just afraid to do that?
Because when we do these meet and greets
after the peterson events,
I think the number one question I get
asked is what can I do?
I'm afraid to speak and I cannot.
I mean,
I see this,
you know,
from people that I'm sitting this close
to and I see this look in their eyes of
fear and it's like,
I don't think I'm that brave.
I don't know why I'm doing this.
I don't.
I'm just doing it.
I can't explain it,
but I don't wake up every morning and
I'm like,
what am I going to do today to fight
Google and fight the political powers?
Or I'm just like,
I'm just doing what I think is right.
That's it.
That.
So that goes to.
I brought my family thousand 11 to
Auschwitz and I did it again because I
see over the horizon I think and we
stood outside of the gates and we had a
prayer and then I said,
okay,
we are here because we have to look at
the ugliest thing man has done and we
have to decide who we are,
who we're going to be.
Because if you weren't prepared,
and I don't mean prepare for that kind
of stuff.
I mean really know who you are.
You will not stand when the jackbooted
thugs come down the street.
You have to know who you are and what
you believe.
So I had them read a story of the
righteous of the nation.
They could pick anyone who saved Jews
and really try to get into their head.
I lined up in a,
a just a family kind of conversation
with this sweet woman.
She just died,
I think last week,
90 years old.
She was a Christian.
She was 16 years old when she saved the
first Jew.
Her whole family did it.
It was remarkable.
Um,
and we,
we talked about it.
Two things I learned on that trip.
One,
as we were leaving,
I said to her,
look,
I have a responsibility that's different
than most because I speak to so many
people.
And I said,
I believe that people have that tree of
righteousness in them.
I think they have that goodness.
They want to do the right thing.
How do I water it?
She told me something so profound.
It's so game changing.
She,
she looked at me so puzzled and she
said,
you misunderstand.
The righteous didn't suddenly become
righteous.
They just refused to go over the cliff
with the rest of humanity.
All you have to do is remember what
you've always believed was true.
And they just stand and just go,
no,
you guys are crazy.
You don't have to be a hero.
You're not a hero.
She was looking at me.
She wouldn't let me film her.
She only let me take one picture of her.
She wanted to nothing because she's
like,
I'm not a hero.
I just remembered what was right.
That's remarkable.
Do you think that the default position
of humanity is to cower?
That is that in these moments it seems
like it's a lot easier to cower,
right?
I mean even now,
like that's the thing when people say
this to me about how do I get braver or
whatever,
it's like we live in the freest place in
the history of the world and if you're,
if you're afraid now,
imagine the second.
That thing gets turned a little bit
about how afraid you are going to be.
So it seems like like fear,
and I'm sure there's a psychological
component to this,
that fear does something in the brain
that may be bravery or,
or maybe it really is about just knowing
what you are and what do.
Let me tell you two stories.
I'm a first fear.
Shuts your brain down.
Okay.
It's shuts reason down.
You're in fight or flight and that's a
good thing because you don't want to be
going,
well,
I don't know.
Should I hit them a little harder
swinging,
so fear and anger really bad and that's
why we're addicted.
Outrage.
We will swing.
You've got to get shake that or your
won't think it's biological.
Two stories.
Um,
the other person we met with in Poland
was the chief rabbi and he said,
I think it was 7,000.
There were 7,000
people that stood.
And I was,
I mean,
when you,
have you been outwards?
Now I have it when you go,
there's churches,
I mean a block away.
There are houses everywhere.
And they were old.
They were there.
And I left there and I was enraged.
I remember her crying and,
and looking at the houses and screaming
in my head,
where the hell were you?
Where were you?
I meet with him and I said,
how out of all the millions of people,
and he said,
you,
you're thinking that's a small number.
You said that's an incredible number of
people.
People you're in a scary movie.
You look away when something like this
is coming,
it is human nature to look away or to
dismiss and you,
you,
it's,
um,
we have this gift of fear that warns us,
but we use logic and sometimes we use it
just to protect ourselves because Dave,
I don't think people are afraid of
standing.
I think they're afraid of knowing the
truth.
You look at the people who stand,
the people who stand are the ones who
are going,
you know,
I learned something new.
I learned something.
It's changed me.
They're not standing.
You're not standing because you're brave
and I'm going to take a stand.
You're saying,
wait a minute.
I just scales.
Fell off my eyes.
I just learned something.
When you are inquisitive,
when you are based in,
wait a minute,
I,
I really want to know you have already
prepared to hear,
but do you really,
you and I,
I know you know this.
I think we've talked about it.
I went through it and you went through
it.
You do come to a point to where you're
saying,
if I take another step,
everything in my life could change,
my friends might change.
They might look at me differently and
you take that step and say,
yeah,
I want to know the truth.
That's where people fail.
They.
If you can't take that leap,
and that's why I really think you're
seeing people like you.
You're seeing the inquisitive because
that's in their nature to question
question,
wait a minute.
That doesn't make sense.
That doesn't make sense,
and if you're like that,
you most likely have already passed that
line of uncomfortability because you've
had things that you realized you went,
Oh crap.
Okay,
well I guess I don't believe that
anymore.
Yeah,
and I just don't know how I could wake
up and put stuff in my hair and look in
the mirror and go,
that's why I just don't know how I could
do it,
but I know some people do it and then I
get.
I think this is what Jordan would
describe as sort of the slow road to
hell.
You will just diminish yourself and
diminish yourself every everyday of your
life until the end.
You have to stop looking.
You have to turn around because it will
always present you with the option.
Oh,
you saw it.
You looked out and you saw them just
lining up a family of Jews shooting
them.
Okay.
Now what do you do once you see it?
It presents you with a choice.
Do I go back to sleep or do I stand so
I know every.
You know,
it's very easy to always be like,
okay,
both sides are going crazy.
They're equally horrible and all of
those things like that.
Sort of like the easy,
the easy way of doing it.
I'm not saying that that's what you're
doing here,
but that's sort of the easy way to do it
and we all fall in that trap sometimes,
right?
Because just for brevity sake,
sometimes it's easier to say that,
but it seems to me that for all the
people that that absolutely despise
trump,
that,
that hate everything about the right,
the right basically has been in power
for last two years.
There's a lot of good things happening
in the country related to economics and
the fact that we're not entering foreign
wars and there's some interesting things
happening with North Korea in a series
of other things and the state has not
used its power to silence anyone.
What I fear,
and this is why I don't think it's an
even,
oh,
both sides are crazy thing,
is that the left is about state power
and what I fear is they've said,
well,
half of the country's Nazis,
we cannot be civil with them because
they're coming to get us and if these
people took power,
well now we have everything that you
just laid out because they don't mind
using the apparatus of the state to
accomplish their goals,
and I'm not saying Republicans are
always write about this stuff and they.
They screw up all
the little government things that they
should care about and all of that.
The left has become everything.
They said the tea party was that we
weren't.
We weren't.
They have become violent.
They have become unreasonable.
They want to silence people and they
will silence people.
That's why you're seeing people's start
begin to stand up and say,
ha,
um,
however,
it's one of my fears with Donald Trump.
And the great thing is he says a lot and
most of it never happens.
You know what I mean?
My fear is,
um,
he has said,
you know,
maybe we should look into the license of
these companies.
You know,
I don't think he means it,
but you signal that to people on the
right or the left your,
you're basically saying,
yeah,
that's on the,
that's on the field of play.
It's not on the field of play.
Um,
although there's an interesting
libertarian argument whether the
government should be giving licensing.
No,
no,
no.
I don't think they should have license
at all.
Right,
right,
right.
I don't,
I certainly don't want the government to
say,
you know what,
you've been a little harsh,
so I'm going to look into your life.
No,
right.
Not at all.
Get them out of that.
Here's the,
here's the thing that people aren't
thinking about.
Government is about to become,
unless it marries into it,
pretty inconsequential because it will
never be able to keep up with
technology.
So it was that the saving grace here?
No,
not that I was going to give Google a
lot of the left is concentrating their
power in silicon valley and that's where
you can really silence people.
The guy who wrote IBM and the Holocaust,
um,
gosh,
I can't remember his name.
Really Brilliant Guy.
Well thought out.
Um,
we were talking and I'm talking about
how the Germans,
how they silence people and how they,
they coordinate people off and then just
get smaller and smaller groups and then
they eventually put you behind a wall in
a ghetto.
Well,
they would build the wall higher and
higher so people couldn't hear or see.
Isn't that what Google and facebook are
doing?
We're building digital ghettos.
We have the ability now.
You can speak all you want Dave,
but I'm changing the algorithm and
you're not going to be heard.
I mean,
you look at what the deal with facebook
was.
I promote them.
I give them my 10 million listeners and
I say,
Hey,
you can find me at facebook.
Let's communicate.
Then they take those listeners that
said,
I want to hear from him.
Yeah,
and then they changed the algorithm and
I can't communicate to my own people.
Yeah,
and know this is happening across
the board.
You probably saw my insane tweet thread
about all of that.
I just started tweeting all of these
people,
real people,
not Russian bots,
Russian avatars.
I was taking purposely real people with
real names and real pictures and they're
all saying they're unsubscribed.
There were people who pay.
It wasn't just the free people,
it was the people who pay for Youtube,
red or youtube TV still getting
unsubscribed and it's like,
what did we all sign up for here?
But there I do.
You like the biblical analogies.
I'll do one here.
There was David versus Goliath and I
think dave can take down Google
this.
Dave.
I think there's a chance.
I mean,
I think that story,
I'm being slightly hyperbolic obviously,
but I think that these things have
become so big.
I mean,
this I guess is what the essence of the
story was,
right?
That this Goliath,
this Google has become so big that it
will crumble under its own,
under the weight of its own crap,
basically,
that there will be enough people inside
the broken machine that will wake up
that hope that individuals basically,
I hope all you got is hope,
right?
Yeah.
And your,
your three to five years away from it
being a cage,
I mean,
their behavior with China,
which I outline in the book is pretty
horrific.
Um,
what China,
what the road China is going down is
terrifying and Google is right there
with them.
Um,
and that is evil.
That is evil.
He said,
don't be evil.
That is the definition of it.
Um,
and if they just slowly,
you know,
the guy who closes the door on the gas
chamber was most likely a guy that was
fixing trucks before the war and a
normal guy.
You don't suddenly become evil.
You slowly move into it.
Especially if you're surrounded by a
group of people that are all absolutely
convinced that they are right and the
other voice is wrong and therefore we
just have to filter them out with ai and
the way they are gobbling,
um,
it's really disturbing and the problem
is going to happen.
You know,
we're going to start hitting massive job
loss,
probably 20,
20,
21,
22.
That's when you're going to really start
to feel the effects of,
of Ai.
Um,
when that happens,
if you look at history and we know it,
all the politicians now are saying,
I'm going to get those jobs back from
China because they're leaving China
because they get into expensive in
China.
So you're not getting those jobs back.
And especially because a ai and robotics
are,
are growing.
We'll have 30 percent unemployment by
20,
30,
30 percent permanent unemployment.
So you look at this,
what do politicians always do?
They got to find a bad guy.
Well,
right now it's China,
but as soon as people realize that,
wait a minute,
it's silicon valley that's taking my
jobs.
The then says it's those people,
those people that are building the
robot,
unless those people also see over the
horizon and become buddy buddy with
their friends in Washington and they
work together.
Then you have a surveillance state that
I don't think we ever get out of.
That's a lot.
That's all right.
So I think the first time we sat down,
I think I asked you this,
so this seems like the right segue for
it.
So for everything that we've talked
about here and the addiction to our age
and all that,
there's going to be a certain amount of
people that are watching this and going,
wait a minute,
Glenn Beck was one of the people that
was peddling this stuff.
[inaudible]
I as well.
I think I know you pretty well right now
and I feel like you are honest in your
beliefs and you've.
You've had some mayor Kulpa is about
some of the things you've said.
Even just a.
You got into something on twitter with
my friend in new eyes and you fully.
He sent you a clip of something that you
did about him a couple of years back and
you fully,
you apologized immediately.
You said,
I'd love to talk to you and learn more.
And all of those things.
Just about him today.
What he's coming in.
Yeah.
And I know and I loop you guys in an
email.
Right.
So,
uh,
is there anything you can add to that
about just sort of how you've changed?
Like,
do you remember a moment,
was there something about that?
Because maybe there are people that are
going down that road right now that's
still want more of the outrage and
stiller is still are,
you know,
as they call it,
shit posting on twitter and the rest of
it.
Um,
if you were trying to get somebody to
turn back.
No,
because they were really personal
experiences.
I went from the,
you know,
that,
that global poll that comes out around
Christmas time,
you know,
uh,
most admired man of the world.
Yeah.
I was tied with the pope just behind
Nelson Mandela.
Okay.
That's insane.
Twelve months later,
I'm no longer on that list.
I'm hated.
I was saying the same things on CNN,
but I was saying on Fox.
Okay,
so that was confusing.
Um,
and it was,
you know,
you can't be hated by half of the
country.
I mean,
unless you're just a maniacal,
you know,
ego maniac that is just beyond any kind
of redemption.
You cannot be hated by half of the
country,
you know,
a,
a false hero for the other half of the
country and not go,
okay,
I'm not that.
I don't think I'm that.
Yeah.
So who am I?
What part of it most people will go,
well,
they spent millions of dollars to
destroy my reputation,
to take things out of context.
And they did.
But I also did things because my
philosophy at the time was if I can get
enough eyeballs,
if I can get people to watch,
which puts me in leader Hosan,
you know,
singing Edelweiss,
I can get people to watch.
Then I present them with facts and my
opinion of where it's going.
It forget about everything else.
They'll hang onto the facts and someone
in the press will go,
I hate that.
So I'm going to prove him wrong.
They never did.
They never would look at the facts.
So this is always where they just want
to belittle you and changes to silence
us
and I and I helped them.
Okay.
I added to that.
So I'm not saying it's somebody else.
I am taking my,
my responsibility.
But the biggest thing is now on the
other side,
I can look and say,
wait,
all of you in the press,
you said I was the worst.
Let let me go get the transcripts.
See what I just said.
That's what you said to the 10th power
right here.
It's,
they won't work.
It's wrong and it won't work,
but nobody wants to do that.
Nobody wants to look.
They.
Everyone wants to point to the other
person.
Nobody's willing to go to me.
But you think that 70 percent that you
mentioned before,
maybe you're starting to do that a
little bit.
I mean,
again,
I'm trying to.
I'm trying to find how to get out of
this and.
And I think that 70 percent where I'm
meeting,
I know it's a select group because
they're coming,
they're coming to see me and Jordan and
take 70 percent.
Yeah,
take 17,
10 committed,
10 percent committed changes the world.
Seventeen is your tipping point,
so it doesn't take all of us.
Revolution was fought by about 20
percent of America.
Okay.
Those were the ones who said,
I believe in this.
We have to.
We have to understand it.
A lot of the book is about postmodernism
and how that works and what its goals
are.
What does postmodern even mean?
What is,
what's the modern world?
It's not about a machine.
It's about the scientific process.
It's about exploration and empirical
data and testing a and B and living with
the results.
That's what the modern world is.
So when you realize,
so you would say postmodern really is
anti modern in essence it because it's
going against the ways that we've been
able to measure anything.
The way we've been able to look at it.
Only you can.
When you don't understand postmodernism
and you read the headline,
which I did,
math is racist.
You either go,
these people are out of their minds and
I can't take it anymore,
or you can say,
how?
How did they get there?
When you asked that question,
you start to go and peel the layers down
and you see the core of this idea,
good or bad,
that what came out of the modern era of
the enlightenment was this,
and they say,
this is bad.
This is bad.
That that really is it.
Yeah,
and anything that holds this up must be
destroyed.
If that's math,
if that's you,
doesn't matter.
If you understand that.
It's all about deconstruction and
deconstruction is all about chaos.
You must not do anything to hasten the
chaos it.
You have to restrain yourself.
The best way to fight this isn't about
Gandhi.
Oh,
I want to be just like Jesus.
No,
I want to win,
and the best way to win is to restrain
yourself from adding any of the chaos.
Be Clear,
be stuffed,
spoken.
Be the person that everybody in the
room.
When everybody is arguing,
they kind of look around the room and
there's maybe three people over there
that are just laughing and having fun
and just because you will be the one
that will control the room.
In the end,
everybody else will kill themselves,
but the the majority of people will go,
oh,
I hate this,
and they'll make their way over to you.
That's what we have to do.
We have to stop fighting on the stupid
stuff.
The stupid stuff.
Gay wedding cakes.
Good God,
man.
Feeling homosexuals right now today in
parts of the country.
What do you say?
We start there.
We talk about something that really
makes a difference,
really makes a difference.
We get to the gay wedding cakes.
No,
it was just let's be good people first.
Yeah.
It's so interesting how people just
don't want to do the intellectual work
and now it's like we have these,
we have these phones.
We have endless distractions.
To the point that perhaps 20 years ago
you might have a moment standing on a
corner waiting for a friend to go to
dinner where you'd have to think,
but we can distract ourselves to the
point where we actually never have to
think anymore.
When was the last time you just stood
somewhere?
I mean,
I know you're aware of all of this
stuff,
but where it was say,
have you,
Glenn back just stood somewhere on the
corner waiting for your wife to meet you
and you weren't looking at your phone or
you weren't.
You know,
I tried to do what you did,
but I can't do it for a month.
Uh,
many employees,
that's a problem.
I only have like five.
Uh,
I,
I try to do it once a week.
Don't make it every time,
but just not going to be online.
Do not pick up your device,
go out on a date with your wife and do
not carry a device.
Doesn't have it with you.
Um,
that's important.
And it's important,
Dave,
because I learned something.
My alcoholism.
I was struggling with so many things
when I was younger,
um,
that I didn't want to think about.
I didn't want to think about,
I didn't want to think about the things
that I had done in my life.
The things that I was,
oh,
poor me about it,
just didn't want to think about it and I
would turn on the radio and I'd turn it
up loud and I'd be driving my car and I
never really consciously connected the
two.
It got to the point where it was so bad
that if I didn't have something to
distract,
I would literally be by myself and I go
la,
la.
Just to block out my thoughts.
Okay.
That's a problem.
And I realized when I was finally no
longer I was sober and not,
uh,
and not just not drinking,
was the time that I was driving
someplace and I must have been driving
for about an hour and I hadn't turned
anything on.
And I realized at one point I'm just
driving and I kind of come to,
you know,
kind of come to thinking,
about what's in the car,
what's happening.
And I'm like,
oh,
I wonder what's in the rate.
Oh my gosh,
I've been alone with myself and my
thoughts for an hour.
That's a sign of mental health.
We're sick,
we're sick.
So in the,
uh,
in the book,
in the forward,
you a very graciously,
and I'm humbled that you did it,
you included me in a list of names of
people that you,
uh,
that you put in there.
Um,
and you know,
ben had this and I wrote,
I even wrote to,
to Ben,
I wrote an inscription on this page like
two days later he calls me,
oh my gosh,
we were with each other for two days.
And he was like,
hey,
thanks very much.
And then like at midnight one night I
get this text,
he's a busy guy and I know to those who
are willing to step out in front of the
crowd to question reason and have
dangerous conversations,
men with whom I may strongly disagree
with at times.
But we'll all,
I will always consider real founders of
reason and contemporary heroes.
Ben Shapiro,
Dave Rubin,
Jordan Peterson,
Bret Weinstein,
Sam Harris,
Jonathan Sacks,
pendulum let
Joe Rogan.
So I thought I don't want to make this
about me.
So the one that I thought was most
interesting,
they're actually with Sam Harris because
I suspect you guys probably,
if he disagrees with Jordan Peterson on
everything,
pretty much everything,
policy,
existentialism,
meaning of life,
the whole damn thing.
You guys probably disagree on
everything.
Plus one.
I don't know if we went through,
you know,
and I thought well this is what it's all
about.
This is what it's all about.
So.
But would you have ever.
I mean 20 years ago,
if you were writing a book,
you would,
we still would have done that when I've
often joked that my library is a library
of a serial killer because
I was too broke to actually go get a
formal education,
so I would go to barnes and noble or the
library and I'd go,
who hates each other,
this opinion,
who hates this opinion,
that person,
and I would read them both and I would
look at them and say,
is there enter anything where they
intersect?
Because that I know is true.
If both these people are from opposite
ends of the spectrum and they both say
this is true.
I know that one line in both books is
true.
Okay,
so start small and build the basis of
truth.
And what motivated me was aligned from
Thomas Jefferson that he wrote to his
nephew Peter car.
Peter's parents had both died when his
dad was ill.
He said,
can you please educate my son when he
comes of age?
So Thomas writes this unbelievable
letter.
You know,
in mathematics,
you have to do this in literature.
You have to do this.
The last thing is religion.
I love it.
It's changed my life.
Um,
when it comes to religion,
above all things,
fix reason firmly in her seat and
question with boldness,
even the very existence of God for if
there be a god,
he must surely rather honest questioning
over blindfolded fear.
We break down on the word honest,
honest questioning.
You and I like each other and get along
because you haven't asked me a setup
question and I've never asked you a
setup question.
It's an honest question.
Hang on just a second.
But that right.
But that,
that is in.
That's good.
Yeah.
That keeps you young.
That keeps you alive.
The minute you start.
I knew my father was going to die.
My father was the kind of guy who always
had a book in this packet pocket.
Okay.
Self educated man and a,
there's always exploring and questioning
and he was so granola,
fruit loop being one with the universe
kind of guy.
And um,
I call them up.
We were best friends for a long time and
um,
I'd,
I'd call them sometimes two,
three times a day and we'd just talk
about books,
we're reading and things.
And did you hear this opinion?
What do you think of this?
We talked about the future of the past,
all of it.
And I said,
Dad,
I just read this fantastic book.
You have to read this.
I'm going to send it to you.
And he said,
that's okay.
And I said,
what?
And he said,
I'm tired.
I think I've learned enough.
Huh?
Three years later he was,
he was gone.
When you,
when you are not,
we're built to explore.
And when you're not exploring
what's left,
w,
what would you be doing if you weren't
doing this?
I told my wife when she married me.
This one reason I've lucked out so much.
My wife hates fame.
She hates wealth.
She hates red carpet.
She ate all of it because she married me
and her family was like,
you know,
got married him.
He is a loser.
He's not going to a but he's not going
to amount to anything.
Um,
when she married me because I'm the
first out of every generation that we
can find going back,
I'm the first male that has not become a
baker.
And so I would probably probably be a
chef in some place or A.
I'm not good at baking.
Yeah,
I was just gonna say,
would you bake me a cake?
That's the unknown.
I'm not good at baking pies.
My father said baking
sun is about formulas.
Cooking is winging it.
Yeah.
And I'm not good with formulas.
Impatient.
You're,
you're,
uh,
definitely a,
a winging it Kinda guy.
So generally speaking,
do you feel it's funny,
the first half of what we've done here
was sorta fire and brimstone sorta or
laying out,
you know,
this is,
this thing could really go off the
rails.
I think the last 20 minutes or so it's
been a little more hopeful.
I'm an optimistic catastrophist you do
not want me.
You do not want to be anywhere near me
on the titanic until we get to the
iceberg.
As we're going to the iceberg,
I'm saying,
are you kidding me?
Have you counted
the lifeboats?
And there's not enough light bulbs.
We're headed into cold area.
If there is,
if these people,
they're going to be irresponsible,
they're not going to pay attention to
the ice,
but they're arrogant.
They're gunna hit the iceberg and all
going to die.
Okay?
Soon as we hit that iceberg,
I'm there.
We're going to make it.
We're gonna make it because I believe
that when people are awake,
they will awaken to who they truly are.
And I think Americans are different.
We have this spirit in his,
of exploration.
We're the people who crossed the oceans
were the people that cross the rockies.
I have to tell you if,
if I were alive during the time when we
were exploring,
I d,
I don't even think I would have made it
past the Missouri,
but definitely I would have gotten to
Denver and went,
okay guys,
I am not knowing any.
We're not crossing.
Okay?
I always think every time I'm on the uh,
uh,
what is it?
The five a that goes by the,
the Getty Museum,
which,
which is that
the four?
Oh,
five,
zero,
four.
Oh,
five.
We bumped to La.
So I,
I,
I see the getty museum up there and I
think if I were a pioneer
and I made it this far,
I would have built my house in this
valley and people would have been on the
top of the hill going,
you should see what's going on.
I'd be like,
I'm done.
But generally people are explorers and
they're good and they're,
they're hardy and they want to live.
I think they do want to live and they
want to live
in peace and harmony.
I think that about the Palestinians and
the Israelis when,
if you could,
and I've done it,
I've done it.
When you don't have a camera in
somebody's face and nobody knows you're
talking,
you sit down in a house of Palestinian
and most likely average person.
They're like,
I don't really care.
I mean I just,
I want to raise my family.
I just want to be left alone.
I want to be able to eat.
I will maybe a little extra money,
sole life,
and I can go off for a nice weekend.
That's people.
It's when everybody starts telling them
it's them,
you know,
that's keeping you down.
That's when there's trouble.
You find it weird in a way that,
um,
we're thought of as political beast
because in a certain way we really
haven't talked about politics here.
And I find now I'm probably less
interested in politics now today than
I've ever been in my adult life in a
bizarre way.
You know what I mean?
Like I still,
I still love it at some level,
but like what we're doing here and what
I think the real conversation happening
in the world right now is,
is not political.
There's a class of people that are
trying to make everything political and
keep you confused and controlled.
Flooding the Russians.
Do you see the latest,
the Russians?
Believe it or not,
the Russians,
one of their,
one of their campaigns happened when,
uh,
I don't remember which was that the
last,
the last star wars movie,
I think.
Oh,
I did see this.
They said that,
uh,
the last Jedi that it was Russian bots,
right?
Well,
that's what Ryan Johnson,
I guess
was there is evidence that they were.
They were politicizing the movie that
they were.
They were putting out,
oh,
you're not going to like that robot
because that robot,
it's all about social justice.
I remember seeing it.
The movie did suck and we okay,
I'm with you,
but what I'm saying is we have outside
influences that are trying to make
everything about politics.
Read the book,
Defying Hitler.
The best,
best explanation of what happened in
Germany.
Ever written by a guy at the time as a
warning to the west go and you don't
know what,
you don't know where we've been.
You don't know what's happening here.
Warning,
and so he,
he really gives you a,
a look at what was happening prior to
and you can see it.
You're like,
oh my gosh,
that's the world trade center going
down.
Oh my gosh,
that's this.
You can see it.
We're repeating it.
And he says,
right,
right around 1933.
Nothing is not political.
There's not one topic
that is political.
When did this happen to us?
It's incredible.
I mean,
just,
you know,
I never watched cable news anymore and I
don't even watch sports channels anymore
because it's all political,
but when I'm doing cardio I'll just flip
channels and everything.
You go to his political.
The view is now always political.
If you're watching women's,
you know,
basically women's television in the
morning.
The ESPN now is political all the time.
I mean,
every channel you probably turn on the
food channel and there's some political
situation happening.
Let me
tell you something that I've never said
out loud.
Only person I think that even knows it
in my own company.
Oh,
Stu,
my executive producer,
I couldn't tell you any of the names of
the people that are running for House
and Senate.
I'm on talk radio.
I don't care.
I pay somebody to look at that.
Tell me what's the balance of the House
for the audience?
It does not affect me one iota except in
the big picture.
Which movement is moving.
I just it.
It's a waste of our time.
Think of how many man hours America has
lost in the last 15 years.
Think of what we could have done with
all of this time.
Forget about the money.
Is that the best argument for basically
sort of classical liberalism or
libertarianism that if we could just
reign this thing in,
that not only could you live however you
want it to live,
basically if the government was just
pretended protecting your,
your life and your property rights,
your rights,
right.
That not only would that be good because
you can do what you want,
but it would actually save you money
until.
But yeah,
he would heal.
You'd still have it.
You'd have it still on the local side,
which would be great that that would
actually,
you know what I mean is you'd still have
people who would try to take the local
area and they'd be the big boss of the
area,
so you'd have those things you'd have,
but at least you'd have a little more
control over that you could control it
or you could move to the next town.
You know what I mean?
San Francisco can be as weird as it
wants to be.
They could live in,
you know,
six feet of human poop.
That's fine if that's what you want to
do.
You know there's an app for the human
poop.
Did you know that?
I'm not kidding.
There's actually an APP that tells you
where human poop is on the streets in
San Francisco.
I'm
literally going back.
It's insane.
I,
I remember saying,
I remember saying to people,
there's gonna come a time where you will
not recognize your country.
What you thought was solid will be
liquid.
What you thought was real will be false.
You're not going to it.
We're not only so far past that point
now to where you're like,
I don't even know who anyone is.
I don't know what is real,
what's I don't know,
up and down anymore.
We're so far past that,
oh,
what's incredible and this is a good
thing,
or could be a good thing because of
technology by 20,
30.
You're not going to recognize it.
Anything.
Nothing will be the same.
It will be the difference between
looking at our lives in 20,
30,
looking back and go and tave you
remember 20,
18 when we sat.
It will be as different than as if we
were sitting in now and going,
man,
can you imagine what 1920 was like?
It's going to
be that different.
You know,
this reminds me of a line.
I interviewed Peter Teal a couple of
weeks ago and he said that crypto is for
Libertarians and ai is for
authoritarians and I think that that
sort of gets to the heart of what you're
saying because maybe what's going to
happen here is that as our institutions,
our political institutions,
academic institutions,
media institutions,
as they become so big,
they can't sustain themselves anymore,
so maybe we will sort of break off into
smaller communities,
whatever that means as well.
Sort of.
That's what the declaration of
independence and the constitution is
encouraged,
break off,
do your own thing.
You should be a little laboratory,
be a little laboratory.
You come up with something great.
I'm sure the other states and the other
cities will adopt it if,
if it works,
we'll love it.
Stop,
stop the,
it's,
it's not one experiment.
Why are we so,
why are we so afraid of that?
Because I pushed that idea constantly
and it's like,
you know,
just that,
that the,
that the laboratory should exist so that
if you want low taxes,
you go here,
but then if that screws over the
schools,
then go somewhere else or whatever it is
that,
that play.
But people are really afraid of that,
that somehow we're not actually America
if we don't live under the same exact
laws everywhere at which,
as you said,
is the antithesis of the founding
documents.
I think people just have been convinced
that
people are not trustworthy.
Well,
people aren't trustworthy if they never
get in trouble if they never.
Banks are not trustworthy.
If they never have to pay for their own
mistakes,
they're not trustworthy.
Um,
when you have to pay for your own
mistake,
you learn that when people generally
become trustworthy.
You brought up Peter Teal.
People ask me all the time,
are you concerned about deeply?
Yes,
I'm concerned about deep platforming,
big time and especially Dave with what's
coming with,
with deep fakes and all.
There is trouble on the horizon.
Peter,
every time somebody says something,
I always say,
no,
the guy who can solve this because Peter
Teal,
because we need a platform and I've been
left and right.
A platform whose charter is the bill of
rights.
That's it.
If you agree with the bill of rights and
you're not trying to shut anybody up,
you believe in these things,
these human principles,
what make us human.
Go on what you think on here.
We're not gonna kick anybody off.
We're not going to do anything.
This is this a place where speech will
be protected because thoughts are
supposed to be dangerous.
It's only the dangerous thoughts that
lead us to the moon.
invented television or the Internet.
It's a dangerous thought that,
that said,
I wonder if I can make fire like the sky
does or that's a dangerous thought.
You're going to burn everything down.
Well,
he didn't.
Yeah.
Well,
I can't say more than if you saw my,
uh,
chat with Eric Weinstein a couple of
weeks ago.
The billionaire class is talking now.
So there,
there is.
I'm happy to hear that.
Yeah.
One other thing on that and then I will
let your staff do other.
I assume they have other work to do
around here.
You people do another work around you
got things to do today.
Do you think that if we get out of this
thing and it and it's basically okay out
of this sort of morass that we're in
right now and that it's basically okay
that we'll look back on this and think,
whoa,
there was something really good that
came out of it because
yeah,
Barack Obama was my biggest nemesis.
You don't know.
You don't know what it's like to come
under attack until the president of the
United States and I've had two of them
now is coming after you directly and
using the force of his friends and
allies to come after you.
Who was the other one they went after?
It was not trump.
It was trump.
Yeah.
During,
but yeah,
at the beginning.
At the beginning.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
So I'm call you after you basically were
like,
all right.
No,
no,
I didn't get anything.
Nothing.
No,
no,
no.
And I'm fine with that.
Um,
uh,
what was,
what were we talking about that will
come out on their side that we'll look
back and this is going to Bama and
Donald trump have been some of the best
things that's ever happened to me and I
don't mean financially or,
you know,
whatever.
I mean as a man because they've both
taken me by the lapels and shoved me up
against the wall and said,
what is it you really believe we are so
blessed.
Do you know that really?
Even my father's generation,
he came at the end of,
you know,
he was born in [inaudible] 26.
So he,
you know,
he saw world war two and stuff,
but anybody who really grew up and lived
from 1946 until now,
we really have been very blessed.
But we've also been cursed.
No one has had to have everything about
them.
Challenged.
I'm a better man.
You're a better man because every time
somebody throws you up against the wall,
we will be a better country.
We'll be a stronger,
more vibrant,
more free people if we behave ourselves
and learn from what's throwing us up
against the wall.
That's how I ended in interview back.
Good work ethic.